look at these two men one was an
ordinary beekeeper and the other Sherpa
guide from over around Nepal
now there's Mount Everest you know for
thousands of years people have tried to
get to the top of Mount Everest
people died doing it it was believed it
couldn't be done they didn't know how to
get to the top of the mountain and
that's what stops most people because
they don't know how as little kids we'd
go mummy daddy I want this and they say
no how are you gonna do that well as a
little kid you don't know how to do it
but they did it in 1953 on the 29th of
May they were the first to to get to the
top of that mountain they stood right on
top of the world do you know there's
been over a thousand people do it since
then I watched a young one being
interviewed not very big she had just
come back from going to the top of Mount
Everest and the reporter asked her they
said how does it feel now that you
conquered the mountain she'd we didn't
conquer them mountain that mountain
can't be conquered we conquered the
limitations that are within ourselves
select the person who is already doing
something that you'd like to do get to
know that person go to the experts for
advice don't ask the first nextdoor your
mother father brother the guy works
beside you because they don't
necessarily know there's no point in
asking a person how to earn a lot of
money if they're only earning ten
thousand a year they don't know they
knew they'd probably be earning a lot
it's like don't go to a sick doctor if
you want to get healthy okay so you find
someone that you can go to for advice
get a real good book and lock into that
book and start studying like I bet this
one looks like a Bible you know but this
is napoleon hill's book Think and Grow
Rich I've been reading this thing now
for 23 years I'll probably read it for
another 23 years I read a lot of books
I've got probably a thousand bucks
sitting in my den at home in my library
but the one that I carry I carry it
everywhere I go and I read it all the
time just thinking oh rich I never
stopped reading it you just watched two
amazing clips from Bob Proctor take the
next three minutes to sit quietly I
think about how you can apply them to
your business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]